[Music]
[Applause]
on our first ever Vegas night
competition what happens in Vegas
apparently stays on the ballroom floor
Heather Morris scored the first nine of
the Dancing with the Stars season for
her sultry tango with felon partner Alan
Burstyn the duo nabbed a 33 out of 40
but the real victory getting a positive
health update from Maksim Chmerkovskiy
who sat out after suffering a calf
injury last week I'm hoping for like a
fool comeback end of this week and then
Sharna Burgess and Bonner Bolton brought
1920s Flair with their Charleston but
didn't seem to impress the judges
earning a 24 out of 40 a drop from last
week's score of 29 out of 40 when we got
upstaged the first thing I said to bono
is I love that you're bummed but I'm
frustrated that you're bummed
I want him to acknowledge the difficulty
of that routine that with the injuries
that we've had to have the coordination
to do a Charleston is I mean it's so
intense and I feel like he did a
fantastic job
the evening was over-the-top and full of
energy but there was one number that got
us a bit emotional
here's Julianne and Derek Hough
performing a routine from their move
beyond tour inspired by their parents
divorce
unfortunately by the end of the night
the lights dimmed for one of these Vegas
acts the couple leaving right now is
Charo and Kido Bruno I'll see you the
parking lot okay what happens if you see
Bruno in the parking lot what's gonna
happen he would stay here you will read
in the paper front page
[Music]
you